[Music]
hello and welcome to dear Hank and John
whereas I prefer to think of it Dear
John and Hank it's a comedy podcast
where two brothers answer your questions
give me to be sued Christ maybe while
the week's news from both Mars and AFC
Wimbledon John what is the elephant in
the room all right Hank three I'm sure
we're gonna have the same elephant in
the room this week three two one
Michael cowork river what the Clark Fork
River
Hank Michael Cohen is the elephant in
the room John I don't know if you know
but for some people the Clark Fork lip
river is actually in their rooms oh
really
yeah we're having like some serious
flooding here in Missoula right now it's
the worst flood in like 40 or 50 years
and you go down to where the river is
and it's getting to the point where the
river is like within a couple feet of
the bridge so usually there's the bridge
and then there's a lot of air right and
then there's the river right and right
now it's the bridge and then a very
small amount of air and then the river
and this makes me nervous because it is
not the part of the flood that is the
peak and what I feel like when the when
the water gets to the wit like where the
bridge is then the bridge goes away
right and I need those bridges to get to
work I mean the bridge goes away for a
while sometimes it goes away forever but
usually it just goes away while the
water is high I am very concerned about
the people whose homes are being flooded
though and that's that's unfortunate to
hear as as someone who lives near a
river I spend a lot of time looking at
the amazing work done by people working
for the US government making sure that I
know what the water level is in never
near my house it's all it's a wonderful
service and I am very grateful for it
and it's one of those things that I
don't think that a private company would
do as effectively as the government does
it so hako just take this opportunity to
say one we're very concerned about
everybody who is affected by the
flooding of the Clark Fork River and to
thank you to all the hard-working people
in government who are
doing great work and who may be often
feel like their work goes unnoticed or
unloved yes absolutely Anna and and also
that's good science that allows us to
better predict what might happen in the
future and and I actually know some
people who work on that kind of thing
here in Montana and yeah it's a little
bit scary to see the river where it is
and and also but it is nice that we knew
we know what's gonna happen we know
what's on the way and people have
already been evacuated and the people
who can protect their homes have already
protected it so I'm glad that we have
the science that allows us to know when
these things are going to happen whereas
we do not have the science that allows
us to know what on earth is going on in
Washington DC well Michael Cohen doesn't
live in Washington DC he lives in New
York so he sort of opened up a new
almost like a new arc I guess in the DC
character universe where it's like you
know it's like the episode of The Brady
Bunch where they all go on vacation to
Hawaii it's a really wonderful narrative
turn but I am finding a little difficult
to follow along with the thing that I
guess surprised me the most was the
sudden and unexpected appearance of AT&T
donating two hundred thousand dollars to
Michael Cohen's I mean consulting
company to learn like they were just
like hey we thought you should have this
money we found it well it was for
insights on the administration well that
doesn't seem legal it is it is it is
probably legal but don't worry a lot of
the other stuff probably isn't I mean
the whoever is writing the script for
the weird timeline in which we find
ourselves
I just want to say that this is
phenomenal
terrifying work like I I am really I I
feel like this is also real so you guys
wherever you are
whoever's running this simulation you
guys are doing an amazing job because I
feel like this is happening right now
it's very it's compelling Anna and I I
had a
a hard time this morning when I was
trying to get to the bottom of you told
me that there was some Michael and I
googled it and there was just too many
things there was money from Novartis
there's money that's being paid out to
from somewhere to someone else but maybe
not to the person that we thought it was
and and then there's money to AT&T or
from a teen and who knows it's it does
read a little bit like a novel but like
a novel that I don't want to read and so
I feel like I've stopped engaging with
it but it turns out that it's also
reality well we don't know that for sure
we could be living in a simulation which
brings me to our first question
from anonymous Dear John and Hank how do
you break up with someone without
absolutely crushing them thanks nan so
so is your suggestion here then to let
them know and and make sure that they
are aware beforehand that reality
doesn't actually exist correct so the
first thing you say is hey so there are
untold trillions of universes and in
many of those universes we are still a
couple but not without great in so many
universes it was perfect and we died on
exactly the same day at the same time
and never had to experience a moment
separate from each other but in this
universe hey in this universe our
relationship has come to an end but
don't worry many other use and other
Me's are having a great time but this
you and this me it's over kiddo
anonymous I'm glad that you came to the
preeminent authority on dumping people
to guys who have only ever been dumped
yeah I don't think either Hank or I has
ever ended a relationship so here's
Hanks advice um yeah I think that you're
gonna have to recognize that this is
gonna hurt the other person and we don't
want to hurt other people but sometimes
that is a thing that you will do in your
life because you have to and and so come
to terms with that and then do it in the
way that seems most likely to be least
her
full but you're never gonna know but but
I will say don't drag it out be very
specific and don't let any bargaining
take place once you've made this call
and I find that this is a important
thing to learn in all kinds of
situations but once once that decision
has been made sometimes it can be easy
to roll it back a little bit because you
want it to hurt a little less but in the
long term it will hurt the least if it
can just end and be ended and that's
from the perspective of someone who has
been dumped but not dumped people that
is how I would prefer to have it happen
to me Hank I think that's good advice
sometimes in life you just have to take
off the band-aid and it hurts and it's
worse off other people's band-aids as I
often do with my children and they're
like dad why are you hurting me and I'm
like because we can't keep this bandaid
on for the next 16 weeks which is your
plan good sometimes you have to take off
other people's band-aids anonymous that
done that and as usual communicate
exclamation point which really almost
everything he ever say boils down to
that this next question comes from
Dennis he writes Dear John and ink I was
thinking about my childhood the other
day and I was thinking about the first
big cultural events I actually
experienced like when you're three years
old and some big event the World Cup for
instance is happening
you don't feel invested in it I mean if
you're American even thirty year olds
don't feel invested in it but eventually
you start to connect to events like the
Berlin Wall collapsing or the election
of the first african-american president
so when do people become culturally
aware and what were your first cultural
memories using my dendrites Dennis I
really like the idea that the the Berlin
wall collapsed the Berlin wall collapsed
thing sounds like if I think it was some
kind of weird disaster and right lots of
people yeah like there was yeah as a
result of an earthquake
unfortunately the Berlin Wall has
collapsed and as such Germany will now
be reunited great worker earthquake if
only I would also have been hilarious if
like the presidents of East Germany and
West Germany were like
well I mean we wanted to stay separate
nations but the wall collapsed so there
was he gonna do we don't have money to
put up a new wall those things are
expensive
I'll be sure you could afford it in the
sixties anybody could put up a wall back
then but these days with the cost of
concrete let's just become one country
uh-huh and oh god it's so amazing to me
that that worked and that also that
Germany is doing so well that they were
like let's divide a line down the middle
of us for four decades and then one day
you know we're gonna put it back
together and then and then in 30 years
we're gonna be the only thing going in
Europe well I've got a staff Europe I
wouldn't say that I mean that if nothing
else Slovenia is doing great I it is it
is amazing to me and it's a reminder
that history is not final and what feels
intractable often in the end isn't it's
just that it's hard to see your way
through to the end that that was the
first that was one of the first things I
remember I also remember the Tiananmen
Square protests very vividly I watched a
lot of that on television and I remember
feeling really hopeful about it and then
when the military came in and a lot of
people were killed at the end of those
Tiananmen Square protests it was really
heartbreaking for me and in fact one of
the first like grown-up books that I
read when I was 11 or 12 years old was
written by a Chinese dissident about
that experience of being one of the
hunger strikers in Tiananmen Square so
that was the first thing I remember what
about you Hank what so as far as like as
far as like international relations goes
like that kind of awareness
I remember when Czechoslovakia became
two different countries the Czech
Republic and Slovenia and that or the
Czech Republic insult the Czech Republic
in Slovakia and that was like Oh
countries can change and that was that
was a little bit of a thing and I was in
it was in school enough that we talked
about it that in school I was yeah and
then but the election of George Bush
like that was sort of the first election
I was aware of and awake for but I think
also like it isn't just these
International Relations things like the
world like things like the World Cup for
me I think one of the first things that
I felt like I was connected to in
culture was like Michael Jackson's
Thriller
oh yeah like like this is a thing that
is happening in my world and it is
happening to me and also everyone else
right for me it was Tiffany's album with
the single I think we're alone now which
is yes hell that's slightly less well
then Thriller find out I'm still not
totally embarrassed of I recently
really I recently relist into that song
and you know it's not bad no no I love
it it's great I think we're alone now
there doesn't seem to be anyone around I
mean that's well it's a it's a cover it
wasn't even originally Thomas I know but
Tiffany made it her own Hank she
completely reinvented that song and it
wasn't until Tiffany was singing it that
I think we all understood what it meant
to be alone now did you know John I
can't write that Laura Laura came out in
1982 so it obviously wasn't that for me
because I was - that was around for
thriller coming out I I remember so
vividly two-year-old Hank just
moonwalking across the carpet the first
guy in line at midnight to buy thriller
from Tower Records well it was still a
big deal when I was paying attention yes
we had the vinyl and I thought it was a
good good vinyl to have we did have the
vinyl it was not the first vinyl album
we purchased that was I think well owned
now but we did of the vinyl which is
pretty cool and Michael Jackson was
indeed still famous throughout your
childhood Hank so I think it's a
legitimate famous I think it's a
legitimate memory well I definitely
remember Weird Al Yankovic's fat yes
that we're talking about that
yeah probably probably at this point
that was a bad call Weird Al but it
worked in the moment but I
remember bad coming out and that being a
deal again I do not think that you
remember bad it was seven I remember bad
okay I know what I using video you know
what I remember the movie gremlins oh
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah and how
passionate like we thought the movie
gremlins and Empire Strikes Back were
about as good as each other both being
completely perfect yeah yeah in the same
with Goonies like oh no that was 85 and
he's still a great movie it is a great
movie do you remember Hank the two
movies that we owned on VHS when we were
children is it I I think the neverending
story and grease to grease to is correct
we got the neverending story a little
later we had Ghostbusters in Greece too
for the longest time those were only on
VHS I don't know about you Hank but I
was fully 35 years old what I've
realized that Greece too was not the
original Greece yeah well yeah like I
thought that I thought that Greece too
was a sequel to the musical I think that
I realized that there was a movie
correct that's exactly what I thought
III thought that Greece too was the
canonical Hollywood story of Greece in
conversations to me occasionally you
know Greece doesn't come up that often
but I'd be in conversations with people
and they would talk about the movie
Grease and I would just be sitting there
thinking have these people even seen the
canonical Hollywood version of Greece in
which yeah an English person about rides
a motorcycle and etc he does a big jump
big jump I mean I can picture every shot
in that jump sequence in in my mind
right now we must have seen that movie
500 times I recently re-watched it and
you know John it's not that bad it's not
that bad
really doesn't make much sense and there
is a clear distinction between the two
different songwriters so that there are
two different people who wrote the music
for that movie and it was clear that one
of them did
some songs and then they were like we
need somebody else real quick to do
something that aren't this bad and and
there's a very clear distinction between
those two people and also it it does not
make a lot of sense in terms of
narrative arc right but it's really good
it's funny you should say that because
it's one of the worst rated movies on
the entire database for IMDB oh no it's
rated a four point two out of ten which
is very low yeah it is that said
thirteen point five percent of people
gave it either a nine or a ten so you're
not alone exactly you're just in a huge
money I always say this is what I always
say to people who are like DC can't make
movies I'm like look somebody likes
Batman vs Superman that's who they're
making the movie for just because
they're not making the movie for you
doesn't mean they're not making a good
movie and also anything with Michelle
Pfeiffer is a-okay in my book I don't
disagree with you but just for context
Batman vs Superman has a much higher
IMDB rating yeah well everybody go watch
grease two and tell us what you think
it's pretty amazing that they remade
grease and there's like one person from
the first grease movie that's in the
second movie cuz everybody was like oh
no that's a terrible idea and I hate the
script so much I loved it
John is it possible that we've spent too
much time talking about grease - or is
that is that what our podcast is now
that's a technical impossibility Hank in
fact I'm so excited to announce our new
spin-off podcast dear Hank and John the
grease - edition in which we do nothing
but discuss grease - we're gonna watch
grease - every week for a year and make
50 - pile oh wow that would be a lot
dear Hank and John and Michael
Carrington this next question comes from
Adrian who asks dear Hank and John and
only Hank and John so winter road splits
that's called a fork in the road would a
cul-de-sac be a spoon in the road not
Rocky's wife Adrian yes
that's done we've done it good job
you've made that happen yes ah it's a I
live at the end of the spoon and then
people will be like what yeah you feel
like I live in the you know the soupy
part of the spoon the part of the spoon
that holds food well usually there's
nobody who lives in that part of the
cul-de-sac
yeah people live on the end of the
cul-de-sac but not in the SU piece but
part that holds the suit oh you're right
people don't live in the road usually
correct yeah great
that's that's that's the hope anyway
really really good point I'm glad that
we made that happen
along with our new grease tea spin-off
podcast this next question comes from
Jack who writes Dear John and Hank I had
the most amazing Indian food of my life
last week after finally stepping out of
my comfort zone to try something new
today and that same spirit I tried
another new place and it was terrible I
don't make a lot of money so I basically
just paid ten bucks for a bad lunch
experience how often do y'all try new
food places how often should I once a
month once a year never and I should
just stay home and eat ramen apostles
and falafels Jack I don't see what
apostles have to do with it no but maybe
that's the restaurant that he went to
that was bad
may I it's called apostles and falafels
don't go there you guys crying the
falafel is very dry I how often do you
go out and you have a meal where you're
like that was bad uh two or three times
a year I'm gonna go with never never
ever do I get food that I am like that
wasn't good I just can't bring myself to
not enjoy every food oh I definitely can
about four months ago I had a meal and
then 45 minutes later began vomiting
well yeah
no but did you like the food when you
were eating it I mean Hank I have to
tell you I don't know if you've ever
vomited but it really ruins your memory
of whatever happened before you vomited
I really becomes like the central memory
of that eating experience is like 35
seconds after I swallowed the last bite
I was like I feel a little weird and
then 45 minutes later
I you know began vomiting so right did I
enjoy the meal I'm gonna I'm gonna say
no what if it wasn't the meal that did
it
this is what I always think about food
poisoning because it can it can happen
like anywhere from like from like
immediately to seven days after you eat
the thing and I feel so bad for all the
times when I've eaten food and then
immediately started feeling nauseous and
then got food poisoning that I'm blaming
that restaurant I don't know who
actually did it maybe I just got some
like baby poop on my hand and that's
what it was like I don't know what did
it I don't know if it was the Taco Bell
or if it was the or if it was just
living in the world being surrounded by
other people who are gross yeah okay but
to return to the question I think sure I
guess you should be eat out at a new
exciting place I would say twice a year
yeah I'm not a risk taker
I find restaurants that I like and I
patronized them relentlessly yeah no I
mean the people who work at the places I
go to are like hey Hank I will say that
I mostly go to new restaurants on
recommendation so a friend of mine will
be like have you been to that new
Japanese place in town it's amazing and
then I'll either go and tell them that
it was wonderful or I'll go and I won't
tell them how much I found it lackluster
there you go but John the thing is I
like like a six-piece Chicken McNugget
almost as much as I like very fancy
sushi I'm sorry can we roll back the
tape there real quick and see if you
just said sushi did I say sushi I think
you said something close to Shushi I'm
just gonna have Nick play it twice right
now
very fancy sushi very fancy sushi it
doesn't sound totally correct to me but
it is how I'm gonna say
shoo-shoo from now on this next question
comes from Luke who writes it's your
John and Hank my girlfriend and I have a
touring cabaret show in Australia that
is starting to slowly grow in popularity
I'm late not since
so it didn't happen not since the
competitive pokemon player rode in have
I been so taken with the first part of a
question oh man why am I not logged into
the VR Hank and John part of that
process is creating merchandise to sell
at our touring Kappa ratio gigs a
graphic designer friend of ours has
created a shirt that we both really like
but it has our faces featured quite
prominently on it and this makes me
really uncomfortable
how do you get used to your face being
on other people's torsos Oh a Star Wars
reference how original
Luke that's a great name sign up I can't
imagine it gets old being a Luke Luke I
have my face on a lot of merch and I
don't mind when other people are wearing
that merch but when I'm wearing as I
sometimes do because I find Pizza John
shirts to be very comfortable and the
Pizza John hoodie is incredibly
comfortable as I sum and available now
at dftba.com I do feel super
uncomfortable wearing my own merch
because occasionally people will be like
I'm sorry is that your own damn face
[Laughter]
t-shirt you absolutely do fazil oh I so
for Luke I gotta say to you that you
stand on a stage and you do a touring
cabaret show and Australia you cannot be
a super modest person you're just gonna
have to own this it's good merch and
it's got your face on it because you're
part of the show and you're part of the
thing that you're doing and it's called
I dated Batman and you can find it at I
did it Batman comm check it out it's
available all over Australia there's
upcoming shows in places but you got to
follow them on Facebook because that's
what it says follow us on Facebook for
news about shows that's great I dated
bad right that's I that's so cool
congratulations to Luke and Luke's
partner but real quick Hank just to
confirm that doesn't mean that you
should feel comfortable wearing your own
merch on your own body I don't I don't
know it seems
like he's a confident guy he does a show
he doesn't show where people look at him
and that's scary that's got to be
scarier than wearing your own face and
it's not just your face not like pizza
John it's just one of the people on your
shirt as your face and also do you have
to ever wear your own merch because in
general when I'm at like a YouTube event
and there's a youtuber wearing their own
merch I'm like hey you could have picked
somebody else you like there's other
youtubers that have merch right that's I
guess what I'm talking about
when you're a band you don't wear your
own t-shirt like the Eagles don't get on
stage wearing an Eagles t-shirt I don't
know why I've picked the Eagles but I'm
rolling with it like you don't get on
stage when you're 72 year old Don Henley
and play Hotel California while wearing
an eagle shirt I mean a real quick egg
not to the podcast just for fun let's
play a game we're back and forth we name
Eagles songs until one of us loses okay
any Hotel California I think you may
have one with that the Eagles
I think that's brought it was the Eagles
in which case cuz we definitely listen
to desperado a lot as children and I
don't know about my god
and that song makes absolutely no sense
why don't you come to your senses
you've been out riding ridings stop what
is yeah I mean I was riding Phil he has
not come back he's not he doesn't have
his senses John he's out of his mind
he's riding a fence potentially a barbed
wire fence it's dangerous desperado okay
riding fences does have a meaning okay
what is riding fences and also did the
Eagle sing desperado that I can't answer
Cowboys go out riding fences to ensure
that livestock don't stray fences in
that sense always need mending and it's
part of the cowboy life that gets you on
horseback and sort of out cowboying even
if you're not handling cattle okay so it
just means like he's just been
observing a cowboy for so long now that
said the song is bad and it well and I
know Don Henley's a big fan of the pod
and I don't want to hurt his feelings
but I've listened to that song I mean
not like way more than I've seen grease
too every time we went to Bea's diner
for some reason I and it's met it could
just full of cigarette smoke and that
guy that didn't have a mouth and yeah
and we get grilled cheese sandwiches and
dad will put desperado and and love as a
rose on the jukebox like like this is my
big dad living his best life and I'm not
gonna take that away from him first off
love is a rose is a great song so um a
little hurt that you're throwing it on
there saying those are the two songs he
always picked yeah I mean it's funny you
should say that because I had not
thought of bees barbeque since I was
like 9 or 10 years old but you're
absolutely right
Youth barbecue around anymore it must
not be that oh my god great question
Hank okay first off bees barbecue
Orlando Florida nope this restaurant is
closed is not open anymore there's lots
of places that look very good in Orlando
now it's gotten so fancy I know Orlando
is a completely different city from when
we lived there but that doesn't mean
that I can't have a really strong
opinion about it anyway did we answer
the question Wow bees barbecue a
desperado in the years dear ANCA John at
my house I have a 30 pack of pop chips
with three flavors sour cream and onion
sea salt barbecue and you got three
flavors in the 30 pack you would assume
that they'd be 10 of each but you would
be mistaken because there's 12 sea salt
12 barbecue and only six sour cream and
onion it's deliberate since that's how
it's labeled on the box
are they assuming sour cream and onion
is the lesser flavor what if I like sour
cream and onion chips from Meredith well
if what if you do because of course it
is not the lesser flavor it is the
quintessential flavor I mean I've never
felt less close to you than I do in this
moment so
I'm an onion so there's I feel like
there's there's non flavored chips and
if there was one flavor that's not non
flavored chips its sour cream and onion
you are objectively incorrect there is
no way that America's second favorite
chip flavor behind just salted thank you
there is no way sour cream and onion is
second I'm googling most popular
American potato chip flavors we Google
way too much in this podcast Hank I
actually have an answer according to
statistic aam the most popular flavor
chip by far is plain and the second most
popular is wait for it barbecue
I think the pop chip did this did pop G
because pop chip is reflecting a larger
or maybe consumer taste maybe that box
that box though prefers barbecue to sour
cream and onion is the reason why
barbecue took over that market share
sure great point great counterpoint Hank
which came first the chicken or the egg
the chicken definitely came from okay
well in any case I think there was a
time when sour cream in would have been
first oh really what's I don't John is
it sour cream and onion don't leave me
hangin Oh
third is sour cream and onion yeah
fourth salt and vinegar yeah
fifth cheese question mark thank you
like cheddar those are human ruffles
those things are dope I love them I want
to put it in my mouth right now
[Applause]
jalapeno and then in eighth place
no salt / low salt that's not a flavor
and I am offended which reminds me
though John that this podcast is brought
to you by no salt / low salt potato
chips
of course this podcast has also brought
to you by the collapse of the Berlin
Wall the collapse of the Berlin Wall
facilitating one Germany since 1989 and
as
guess it's also brought to you by bees
barbecue it smells like like really old
fry oil and cigarettes and the jukebox
has all your favorite Eagles hits bees
barbecue doesn't exist anymore I mean
Hank it the way that you described these
barbecue just now like brought it into
my mind in the most visceral way I can't
even tell you how much I loved bees
barbecue or how much I miss it
considering that I literally have not
thought about it in 25 years
and lastly today's podcast is brought to
you by our actual sponsor for the week
Skillshare Skillshare is a place where
you can go and learn about how to do all
kinds of things it's an online learning
community with over 20,000 classes and
things like design business technology
tons and tons and tons of stuff I use
Skillshare because John I don't know if
you know this but I do a lot of graphic
design but I do a lot of graphic design
and programs that I learned how to use
in 2004 which is a huge problem for all
of my graphic design co-workers who use
programs that happened now and so I have
had to relearn how to use Photoshop and
illustrator because those programs have
changed a lot over the last decades and
and Skillshare has been really really
valuable for me so that I can work with
designers who are in their 20s and not
approaching middle age approaching a
i-i-i love skill share because it helps
me learn about video editing which I
know that I've been doing for 10 years
but or twelve years but you'd be
surprised how terrible I am at it and I
have learned so much about video editing
through Skillshare but there are tons
and tons of classes over 20,000 classes
it really is wonderful it also makes a
great gift I got both my dad and my
father-in-law Skillshare memberships
over over the holidays and they have
loved it right now you can join the
millions of students already learning on
Skillshare with a special offer just for
dear Hank and John listener so you can
get two months of Skillshare for just 99
cents that's two months for 99 cents you
can try it out find out that you like it
as much as we do
you can go to Skillshare comm slash Dear
John right now / - you're Hank that also
works but Skillshare calm / Dear John is
better I track these things so use mine
again 20,000 classes $0.99 two months
it's a great deal please check out
Skillshare comm / Dear John or dear Hank
yeah it's just I always think that
investing in yourself is is the best
investment and and I you know I there's
a lot that you can learn from the
internet but it is great to have these
things that are a little more structured
and also to be learning with other
people we also have a project for also
message from a slice of nerdfighteria to
the pineapples of solidarity which is a1
nerdfighter within a nerdfighter group
making a message for other nerdfighters
in that nerdfighter group thank you for
donating the project for awesome and
here is the message nerdcon
nerdfighteria brought us together and
this group of nerdfighters has become a
life changing community
we spent hundreds of hours in Google
Hangouts across seven different time
zones and we are now best friends travel
companions couples and an ongoing
amazing network of love and support
thank you listeners / green brothers for
fostering nerdfighteria and thank you
pineapples for never forgetting to be
awesome and now excuse me I must dance
which I assume is an inside joke that
just makes me so happy to read yeah
makes me so so happy thank you for
donating and thank you for using the
work that Hank and I make as an excuse
to come together and be awesome together
we got one or two more questions John
depending on how we handle these before
we get to the all-important news from
Mars and AFC Wimbledon it's from Paige
who asks dear Hank and John I live in an
apartment and just now got a new
neighbor what is the best way to greet a
new neighbor do I knock on their door
and give them a baked good do I wait
until we run into each other on the
stairs and say hello do I just ignore
them forever not great at making friends
Paige do not ignore them you must
intervene fairly quickly Paige because
otherwise it's gonna get awkward and
uncomfortable 100 %
baked good knock on the door I made you
this pie let me know if you ever need
sugar I'm happy to meet you my name is
Paige
and then close the door this is actually
kind of shocking to me that this is your
suggestion not because I think it's a
bad suggestion but because it seems like
something you wouldn't never do well so
it used to be that because I don't like
talking to strangers and it makes me
anxious and everything that I wouldn't
welcome new neighbors when they moved
near me but what I realized is that in
the long run it makes it more awkward
and uncomfortable because then you're in
this like in-between space of not really
knowing each other but running into each
other all the time you're in that space
forever yeah it's better to just get
past that space via a baked good we're
in the person's name and then you're at
least able to say like hello Don Henley
I assume is Don Henley who moved in I'm
not positive but you could just be like
hey Don Henley how's desperado playing
every night going
you've been out reading that fence for a
long time Don okay you know that line at
Hotel California where it's like you
know you can get anything you want but
you can never leave what's it like
having to live that experience like you
write that you write that song but then
that also becomes your story yeah wow I
never thought that's that's that's harsh
that's deep John what is why am i I'm
being really unfair to the Eagles and
also I don't think Don Henley is in the
Eagles I think he is he is way better
did it right junket is it possible
though that the baked good is like a
blight from a bygone era and there's
that some new version of the baked good
that could be an introduction like is it
like hey I'm Hank here's my gamer named
you we could play Mario Kart sometime
just look me up I'm on League of Legends
all the time I love the league yeah I
mean definitely possible probably not I
I think just a baked good does the trick
but I too need to squeeze my phrase of
the weekend somewhere so
I know I know what it's like let's move
on to the news from Mars and AFC
Wimbledon this week the news from AFC
Wimbledon Hank I don't know if you know
this but AFC Wimbledon stayed up in
League One oh my god the relief we
finally had an enjoyable game of
football against Barry on the last day
of the season the Sun was shining nobody
cared if we won and we didn't we tied
2-2 we had a two nil lead but we gave it
up and boy that would have been
heartbreaking if we had needed points
but we didn't so it all worked out the
next day came the news that we'd all
been dreading and knowing would come
eventually which is that a lot of
players who have been part of AFC
Wimbledon for a long time are no longer
part of the club
right at the end of the season is when
players get released or whatever and for
really long serving Wimbledon players
are leaving which is difficult including
Barry fuller the captain of Wimbledon
who I made an entire video about him
picking up the ball during that Walsall
game and I really think is a huge part
of the reason that Wimbledon are in
Ligue 1 and a huge part of the reason
why they stayed in Ligue 1 has been the
captain of the club for a while now and
but but he's moving on I don't know if
he'll be retiring or if he'll be moving
to another club also Paul Robinson who
is the rare player who is a legend for
two clubs he's made I think over 200
appearances for Wimbledon will
absolutely be remembered as a legend for
this part of the club's history but
before that was the captain of Millwall
and made like 400 appearances for them
and Callum Kennedy and and George
Frankham both of whom have played for
Wimbledon for a long time Callum Kennedy
I think three different stints for the
club and just a great great person and
from all my interactions with him and
just really sad to see them go also a
lot of other people are probably leaving
although it's not certain yet George
long his loan time is over he's the
goalkeeper he's had an amazing season we
would be very very lucky to hold on to
him it doesn't look like we're going to
and
and the big huge question mark is Lyle
Taylor while Taylor responsible for a
solid plurality of AFC Wimbledon's goals
he's been a just a tremendous force for
the team for the last three or four
seasons and it's really hard to imagine
what Wimbledon are gonna do without him
but he's also you know 28 years old and
he's probably in a position where he can
go and play for a team in England's
second tier and it's very hard to say to
say to a player you know stay and and
don't progress in your career so I don't
know how that's going to work out but it
would be great to find a way to hold on
to Lyle Taylor if we don't we certainly
wish him well and feel lucky that we
have the time with him that we've had
yes well it sounds like that's rough I
don't know if that means that a bunch of
money gets freed up to buy better cooler
more hip and trendy players but but it
sounds like it sounds rough and I hope
that everything works out and that you
you know that that new money comes in
from whatever and that you're able to I
don't know how it works John Hank what's
the news from Mars the Sphinx
so as planned and successfully the Mars
insight Lander launched this last week
or I guess last week when this comes out
and yeah it launched on may 5th which is
my birthday so great birthday present I
actually had an opportunity to go out
and watch the launch that I chose to not
take because it was my birthday and my
family yeah but it's kind of good that I
didn't go out because it was extremely
foggy so fog does not interview in her
interfere with rocket launches so they
went ahead and did it anyway but you
couldn't see a thing it was just a big
glowy mass which makes me think some
about like how SpaceX is so like all
sexy about its launches and they need
everything to look really good and NASA
is just like yeah you can't see it but
we're gonna get this thing off we got to
get it on it's right
and how I sometimes am glad that the
government is in charge of certain
things not being concerned about how
damp the air is when the when the rocket
is launching though I don't know for
sure that SpaceX would be it just seems
like they're a little bit more concerned
with image what with the launching of
cars into space and such so it's headed
off on its way to Mars everything went
perfectly except for the part that
nobody could see it and it's gonna be on
Mars in six and a half months will land
it will drive it will place a
seismometer on the surface of Mars and
it will drive a probe down into the the
surface of Mars it'll like hammer it
down into the ground so that it can if
that probe can feel a little bit of what
like the interior of Mars feels like in
terms of the amount of heat and stuff so
it's on the way and it'll be there and
so far so good John well that is really
really exciting I I can't imagine
I guess it's similar in a way to a
football season to have this six and a
half period where you're waiting for but
good luck way to go wrong because really
it right if there's any news in the next
six and a half months it's definitely
bad and then it's sort of how I feel
about ya AFC Wimbledon season though
I've just always liked God let's just
get to the end of the season and stay up
until we can get into the new stadium I
don't know yeah yeah we've got got one
more year and and by the time AFC
Wimbledon secured League status next
year there will be a new Lander on Mars
yeah and yeah and hopefully everything
will be successful and AFC Wimbledon
will be in the top tier of English
football and humans will be on Mars by
2028 I actually would 100% take that
yeah I bet you would I think that
there's actually if there's anything
that's less likely to happen than humans
being on Mars in 2028 you're not wrong
okay we got a correction from Nate who
says good afternoon Green brothers I was
listening to a recent episode of the
podcast where John talks about going to
the Baltimore Museum for of art for a
year I worked as a security guard at
that Museum and your comment about
openly weeping in front of the art
Burda memory that this happened pretty
regularly while I was working at least a
few times a month I would see people so
moved by a piece that it brought them to
tears I just wanted to comment and let
you know that and let everyone know that
this is okay and you take as much time
as you need to get through whatever it
is you need just don't touch the art
please
exterminate I guess that wasn't the
correction it was just a nice thought
from Nate all right I think what did we
learn today
John we learned that there is a fork in
some roads and a spoon in some others we
also learned that there are lots and
lots of universes in which relationships
are still going on but then there is
this universe in which you've been
dumped and attacked by an owl oh I
didn't hear about that part and we also
learned that Greece too is the best bad
movie you'll ever find yourself watching
and we learned that Hank and John have a
lot of feelings about a barbecue
restaurant in Orlando that none of you
have ever been to and cannot go to
because it doesn't exist for probably
lots of good reasons Hank was your
phrase of the week League of Legends yes
it was I finally got one right it feels
so good felt so don't even in that
moment I was like Oh John is John I feel
very embarrassed I was hoping maybe I
think it was Mario Cart I don't know I
was good it was good who donated to the
p4a to get me to say to get you to say
that that was suggested by Jake who
donated to the project for awesome thank
you Jake and John was your phrase of the
week
Don Henley or the Eagles or desperado or
riding fences or something no it was our
attacks oh my god 45 seconds ago donated
by Johannes thank you Johannes for my
first ever phrase of the week win now
I've learned that if I just wait till
the last 45 seconds of God I can win oh
my god right
thank God it has been a pleasure to pod
with you we're off to go make our hit
podcast this weekend Ryan's available at
patreon.com slash dear Hank John the
best podcast about people not named Ryan
that you will ever listen to at
patreon.com slash dear Hank and John
it's an extremely narrow best but that's
what it is
and if you support us on patreon we very
much appreciate that that money goes to
our educational channels that we do on
YouTube and it's very nice for us to
have that and and that support is so
appreciated John this podcast is edited
by Nicholas Jenkins is produced by
rosianna halse rojas and Sheridan Gibson
our head of community and communications
is Victoria bon giorno the theme music
you hear at the beginning and right now
and during this weekend Bryan's is by
the great gunnarolla and as they say in
our home down don't forget
[Music]